well if you were going to arm a
screenwriter with one tool or weapon
what would it be
a gun what you basically you put it here
this you do the John Milius you'd come
in armed strapped you take your gun out
you put it on the desk in front of the
executive and go so what are your story
knows just do that oh it's a no I I
think I think the thing is a lot of new
screenwriters think that it's gonna be
easy and it's not and they think that
they're gonna write one script and it's
gonna sell and that's not the way it
works it's like you're gonna basically
be you have to love writing because
you're gonna be doing a lot of it and
the you know this was ages ago but the
WGA did a survey and found that the
average screen letter sold nine scripts
before they made a cent and a lot of
people think I'm gonna write two or
three scripts and if that doesn't have
if nothing happens in my career then I'm
gonna quit it's like that's you're
quitting way too early you got to like
stick it out write as many scripts as
you can and eventually one of those
scripts is going to hit and even then
once you've sold a script people ask me
things like so how did you break in and
my answer is which time because it's
like every time you sell a script you do
the rewrites on that script and then
you're unemployed which means you have
to find another job and that it's you're
constantly breaking in you're constantly
having to sell things to people you
don't know you've never met before and
just keep the ball rolling you know
there's only so much that your
representation can do for you the rest
of it you kind of have to do yourself
some extent what do you say to the
newbie screenwriter who wants to quit
their day job and go all in to make this
food I would say don't quit your day job
it's it's one thing if you're if you're
thinking about if you have a day job
that you can move to Los Angeles and
find the same day job it's it's easier
to live here you were talking earlier
about you know meeting Joan Baez I go
into Ralphs grocery store I'm standing
in line behind a movie star or you know
a director or something because they
live here you know and you can easily
bump into somebody that could change
your career
so it's good to be here those things can
happen
I actually one of my script deals came
from standing behind a producer who I
recognized and I basically said I've got
a script in the trunk of my car you know
can I get it for you and he's like well
I don't know man I'm here I'm gonna get
I got to go home and do this and I'm
like well if I get it to you before you
get out of this line and he said sure
and I managed to do that so it was there
was a suspense by the way and the lines
moving but he read it and we didn't buy
that script but we did having a series
of meetings and I end up getting a deal
off it but that's one of those things
that can happen here but if you're
thinking about just basically quitting
all jobs in writing scripts the problem
there is you don't know if 9 is the
average and somebody sold their second
script that means somebody else wrote a
whole bunch of scripts before they sold
one and you may be in trouble you know
it's it's always better it's better to
have the peace of mind of knowing that
you're paying your rent or whatever then
be panicked and going I have to write a
script and sell it by next Tuesday
because that is not gonna happen
did you have several copies of this
script like you know I have the trunk of
my car
actually right now it's on a thing on my
pocket but the trunk of my car I learned
a lesson I went to the San Francisco
Film Festival Robert Evans was speaking
Robert Evans said at the end of his
little speech he said if any of you have
a script now's the time to come down and
give it to me this guy was like the head
of Paramount Pictures at the time and
I'm like I have a bunch of scripts at
home so I learned my lesson and from
that point on I have a box of scripts in
the trunk of my car I probably still
have you know some scripts back there
but they don't get replenished like they
used to with the spare tire and it's
like you know if I'm someplace and I
bump into somebody I've got a script I
can hand them like I said right now
things are like PDF so I can say I've
got it on this Drive can I plug it into
your you know your computer and or your
whatever and go from there so you
literally have like several copies yeah
absolutely
absolutely because you don't know when
you're gonna bump into somebody and it's
better to have you know what else is in
the trunk of your car you know the spare
tire and if you have
and jump but it's like if you have a box
was just scripts in it and have several
copies of your scripts and that and have
a variety so if I bumped into somebody
that was looking specifically for like a
big action movie I had the big action
script I was looking for some if I
bumped into somebody was looking for a
small thriller I had the small thriller
script so I kind of came prepared in my
genre but yeah it's like there's there's
still scripts in the trunk of my car
just you know they're probably old moldy
or something by now so what if someone
said can I buy a cup of coffee and pick
your brain about selling screenplays
what would you tell them in that
ten-minute converse in that ten-minute
conversation what I would tell them is
that a good script honestly kind of
sells itself
and that's the biggest problem is that
people don't have the script that sells
itself a script will open doors for you
you don't have to open the door and that
ends up being the biggest problem people
think there's some trick to it but
there's not a trick to it the trick to
it is to have the script that when
people read it they say I want to spend
money to make this movie and those
scripts are hard to write the the break
thought I had that got me to Los Angeles
was I gave a copy of a script to a woman
I had a crush on them and said there's a
roll in here that's perfect for you she
immediately moved to Los Angeles was in
a B horror movie gave a copy of that
script to the I wouldn't say the line
producer but somebody on the set not the
producer not the big producer but some
underling and said there's a role in
here that's perfect for me he read the
script and goes this is so much better
than this crappy movie I'm working on
now handed it to his best contact I went
to his best contact and that script
traveled and that's what you want is the
script that travels that when people
read it they go I want to be associated
with this project and those are the hard
ones to write those are the ones that
people underestimate how they think
their script is at that level and it's
not there yet and that's that's the
hardest thing is like you need to have
the great script I don't know in that's
writing you know it's the you can sure
there are people who have a relative in
the business to get their script in but
other than that even if your script goes
through an agent or
manager there's a flood of scripts that
go through agents and managers you know
it's like they're still gonna not pick
every single one of those scripts
they're still gonna pick the best of
those scripts and the best of the
scripts sometimes comes down to odd
things like it's you its uniqueness
which is an odd but it's marketability
at that point in time there's times
where a script you could write a script
and I did this I wrote a script that was
about airplane hijacking and then 9/11
happened and so that script was
instantly dead on arrival but the thing
about that script is that pre 9/11 it
was it was it was an okay script and so
that's sort of the reverse of what you
want sometimes you end up writing a
script and then the something happens in
the world and like this is the script
and if you if you have that great timing
you know but you also have to have the
great script to back it up going back to
that film that you had a part for this
love interest yeah yeah how many years
have you been writing before you got to
that point and gave it to that line
producer I gave it to the girl she gave
to the line producer okay I I didn't
want to sleep with the line producer but
the you know I bet that was I'd actually
had a film made by that and then it was
local that's my first script deal came
from a and in the weird old world of 35
millimeter film a guy named Paul
curiosity who went to my Community
College was making drive-in movies
driving kung-fu movies I'm 35 and he
made them in the East Bay Area and we
had become friends I'd actually worked
on one of his films called weapons of
death you can tell it's a Oscar caliber
movie by that title and basically worked
for free every weekend on this film and
so he had read a couple of my scripts
and they were in English and made sense
and so he ended up having a project
where he had a script that was terrible
and he said look we have the cast we
have the location we have a script that
doesn't work if you can give us a script
that does work in
two weeks using this cast and this
location will film your script instead
of this script
if you can't we're gonna have to go with
the other script and so I basically took
two weeks off from my day job wrote a
script against the clock using all those
things and it was of course almost
anything could have been better than
other script but it was better than the
other script and we filmed it in in
Oakland and Walnut Creek and just
basically shot this silly kung fu movie
called ninja Buster's before
Ghostbusters by the way but but after
crimebusters but this silly movie called
ninja Buster's and that was my first
credit I was a big fish in a small pond
for a while and was writing scripts for
any local person that thought it would
be fun to be in the film business and
you know so I sort of did that for it's
probably a year of of making money at it
and then it was back to the day job
you